do you think that the UK should leave
the single market and we've been really
clear I know that it hasn't always come
across that way and their spin and
there's reporting and so on but but but
it's it's the second of our brexit tests
that that any conclusion to negotiations
must involve Britain having an access to
the single market see I'm very free ads
of us knock me back because I do
understand that you're saying you want
our free act as a single market but
labour is also saying that you want to
have control over free movement of
people I mean that sounds a bit Boris
Johnson we hope you know we haven't said
that we'll have control and offering
movement of people you can't necessary
have complete control will be what we
want is to be able to have fair
migration that avoids people's jobs
being undercut well in a labor manifesto
you said that free would end
ok so let me try and try and clarify
this when you leave the European Union
formally there is no longer free
movement under the tree you can stay on
the single market and have removin if
you take the normal order they can but
you have to negotiate that and it may
not be called staying in it's staying in
the free market and having a free
movement it may be called something else
but what it's called doesn't matter
what's important is that jobs come first
the economy comes first and that means
getting tariff free access to the single
market and then dete the formalities we
will negotiate the thing is though let's
get real here you want to fall into the
next government at some point you can
have to decide whether you want to
prioritize yeah
immigration or it is the economy the
economy comes first for you the economy
comes first so in other words you're
happy to sacrifice more control over
immigration to protect jobs I think the
entire shadow cabinet been absolutely
clear this has to be a jobs first
economy first brexit and everything else
has to be negotiated with that priority
in mind so something similar to free
movement of people just under a
different name could happen well I mean
there's a lot of there's a lot of room
for negotiation about what types of free
movement what kinds of priority it's
possible for friendly countries in and
outside Europe to give priority to
certain Nash
we did it for many years with the
Commonwealth we have we have looser visa
regimes with some countries compared to
others so there's a lot of room for
manoeuvre but the priority is clear it's
the jobs and it's the economy first